during last week's first 2020
presidential debate
president donald trump refused to
condemn
the proud boys an organization that
promotes and engages in political
violence in the united states and canada
following the debate actor and activist
george takei
shared his thoughts on the organization
how insecure
are they that they have to go to a
demonstration with
with their weapons and then like like
uh spoiled bullies children
they they react violently i mean that's
not anything to be proud of at all
that's everything to be ashamed of they
are
shameful boys shameful is right
george also tweeted a brilliant idea
writing
i wonder if the bts and tiktok kids can
help lgbts with this
what if gay guys took pictures of
themselves making out with each other or
doing
very gay things then tag themselves with
proud boys i bet it would mess them up
real bad
reclaiming my shine and george's tweet
did
just that the hashtag proudvoice was
hijacked by the gay community
and trended on twitter with photos of
proud gay men kissing and showing
affection
even the official twitter of the
canadian armed forces in the us
shared a photo thank you george for this
i loved it
and george also says that the queer
community really does know
the true meaning of pride we are not
standing back
and standing by we are standing up
and speaking out so we know
what true pride means these
weaklings who need to depend on weapons
to do anything they are
fakes they are not they have not earned
what
the word pride denotes we
march up primaries
because we are proud
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos